love this town the city of endless
opportunity ready to get your cherry
popped
come on city like any other just bigger
my nan I just hit another city legends
are born here
in eight weeks rolling here cuz Dex
pulling the strings doubt that put since
and we've is them but we are they just
don't know it yet but if you got the
cojones and you know how to use them you
could do damn near any
unless you catch it for even then you go
out with the bag right you know you can
make heaps more a motivational speaker
yo mr. V a pleasure so what's the game
Dex
we meant to come out in one piece how
about we go over the plan there's this
prototype tech bio chip to be precise
jobs to clap
Desna belongs to a court arasaka me
Robby some heavy hitters like you can
blackmail me [ __ ]
how is have a war first rule of the
afterlife to cut teenage baby goes
without saying we do this on the hush I
deal in nobodies not a one it sounds
simple enough
[Music]
is it gonna be dangerous don't you worry
more we're bulletproof what the [ __ ]
just happened in there it stopped
digging nice city [ __ ] happy now
Jackie oh my god was so [ __ ]
[Music]
Thanks what the [ __ ]
game risk it be and you who are you
[ __ ]